سنه كانت كافيه لعوده سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه
[تصفيق]
الحكايه بدات مع اندلاع اعمال العنف في
البلاد عام 2011 في الاجتماع الشهير
لوزراء الخارجيه العرب في القاهره تم
اقرار تعليق عضويه سوريا في الجامعه لحين
التزام الحكومه السوريه بتنفيذ بنود
المبادره العربيه تعليق مشاركه وقت حكومه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماع
جامعه مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه القرار
حينها طالب الدول العربيه بسحب سفرائها من
دمشق لكنه اعتبر ذلك امرا سياديا لكل دوله
وزراء الخارجيه العرب اتفقوا ايضا وقتئذ
على توقيع عقوبات اقتصاديه وسياسيه على
الحكومه السوريه مندوب سوريا لدى الجامعه
وصفاحينها القرار بغير القانوني والمخالف
لميثاقها ونظامها الداخلي بعد هذا القرار
الذي تم اتخاذه اليوم بشكل غير قانوني
وبشكل غير ميثاقي منذ ذلك الوقت بقي كرسي
سوريا شاغرا قمه بعد اخرى واجتماعا بعد
اخر ومن القاهره ايضا وزراء الخارجيه
العرب التفقوا على عوده مشروطه لسوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه وفق مبدا الخطوه مقابل
الخطوه مع ضروره اتخاذ خطوات عمليه وفاعله
للتدرج نحو حل الازمه السوريه اتخذت الدول
العربيه قرارا باستئناف مشاركه وفد
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعات
مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات